now I'm going to jog your memory and
yesterday I gave you a puzzle
do you remember it had these three
numbers in it can someone help me
remember what was the 100 about what was
that a hundred kilos old potatoes cuz I
was hungry right 99 what was that about
how much that's how much water started
off in the potatoes right and then what
do I do
I was a bit lazy you left it out it
dried until such a point that there was
only 90 percent water left over okay
sorry 98 percent right so so now I'm
gonna repose that question to you and
this time I'm going to give you a couple
of minutes to actually try and solve it
my original question was okay how many
kilos of potatoes do I have now I
started here what am I gonna end up with
I'll give you a couple of minutes and
he's my big clue for how you might
approach it you don't have to approach
it this way but it's a suggestion if you
think you have an answer come here and
I'll come to you so you don't spoil it
for everyone okay couple of minutes I'm
so you have some solutions I've seen a
couple of people with the same answer
come up with different answers I'm gonna
give you my answer you might be
surprised by what the answer ends up
being my challenge to you would be if
it's surprising number one why is it
surprising is that surprising because
you think it's wrong and if it is wrong
what's the problem like what have I done
wrong maybe you'll be able to find a
step in the working that I'm going to
put it down and you can copy down with
me so you can follow along and if it's
not wrong then could maybe you'd be
right even though it's surprising here's
how I'm going to approach it here here
is my starting situation okay lots of
potatoes
lots of it's water okay now what's
tricky is because I've give it to you
percentages right this is the sneaky
part of it and the counter intrude upon
a lot of people have said to me as their
answer they've suggested well maybe 99
kilos
potatoes are left because it looks like
you've kind of lost one or maybe if you
like really sneaky
maybe it's ninety eight point nine kilos
I left that seems kind of reasonable
doesn't it okay oh oh no equity okay so
in that ballpark here's the way I'm
going to break this down think about
this starting situation a little more
carefully right if they're 100 killers
and 99 percent of them is water then how
much is water is kilos not percentages
it's 99 killers right 99 kilos of you
agree with that okay
now that tells you quite quickly
therefore how much is not water by the
way in case you didn't know ah it's
starch basically right so what's left
over is 1 kilo right 1 kilo it doesn't
see very much does it
that's starch okay not water are you
happy with that
alright now what happens is when things
change okay when you know when I left
them for a week and they probably kind
of turned green and stuff like that grew
shoots water went away water went away
so there's gonna be less water how much
starch went away like they're just
sitting there no starch went anywhere
right all the starch is still there so
how much starch were there but it will
be one kilo of starch still right still
now hold on a second hold on 98 percent
is water so what percentage is not water
two percent right
one kilo starch that's two percent right
okay now the unitary method is really
handy because that's 2 percent
well what's what's 1 percent then of the
actual weight that's left over
it'll be 500 or half a kilo like half a
kilo that's 1% so if I want the whole
thing the actual leftover how do I go
from 1 percent
I multiply by a hundred so like 1 times
100 percent AHA is I'm 0.5 right
huh uh-huh of a hundred I believe that's
50 kilos I should have just waited a
week before I bought it because they
charge me by the kilo right really this
is a bit surprising isn't it this this
percentage has hardly changed but the
weights changed a lot
did you believe it if you don't believe
it is there a target uestion if you're
not believe it he's my working where do
you think you know when magicians are
doing card tricks and that kind of thing
yeah right there's always a trick
there's something it's a oh there's the
thing and once you spot that you know
what right is there a trick here if you
think there is can you find it